the gurgle giving life
and they came from miles away to get it
for many it's a race that they're losing
the race to find oxygen before
coronavirus overwhelms them
quickly he's shouting they know every
minute counts
the narrow street outside the sikh
temple in east delhi
is crowded with vehicles full of sick
and dying people
desperate people gasping for air for
oxygen that the hospitals can't provide
this is many tell us they've been turned
away by several hospitals before
reaching here
no one seems able to help these people
and some
just don't make it in time
this would be shocking on its own but
this tragedy is being multiplied
over and over indians are being
abandoned
in the teeth of a deadly disease the eu
uk and america are amongst the countries
to offer help
but the people have yet to see it so
they're taking it where they can
and this sikh temple's providing it
sourcing oxygen themselves
how do you manage to get oxygen and the
government doesn't
why isn't the government doing it i
don't know what government is doing
people are dying on streets and
governments
are they are watching for all their
votes and election
as seeds i don't know what government
are doing
that then we can do it why can't
government not doing
that's a question a lot are asking
india's grim statistics keep on rising
they're promising free vaccinations for
all but in this
one of the world's biggest vaccine
manufacturing nations
only around two percent of indians are
fully inoculated
and the surge in testing across the
country means these are hard to come by
too
now with the positivity rate soaring
in calcutta at the moment every second
person being tested
is positive in all the chaos
there are many fathers like siddiqui
he's pleading for help my son's weak he
says please come
his son abu sadat is lying motionless
they've been trying to get him into
hospital for eight days
india's being engulfed by this virus and
its people are utterly helpless
they hastily bring an oxygen tank to
hook him up to it
this is the best chance he's had of
making it through this pandemic
in more than a week
he's been pushed out of all the
hospitals his mother tells us
no one would help just as siddiqui is
feeling relief
his son relapses
there's a sudden panic
[Music]
and his brother is doing everything to
push life into him
they're not medics but they love him and
they're worried
and they're not going to give up
siddiqui is distraught and he's angry
the whole country's been destroyed he
says the whole country is destroyed
even with the central government and
state government there's still a black
market for oxygen he says
what can you do now he needs to go to a
hospital
hospital no more beds no more beds in
hospital
this is every family's fight now but too
many are taking on this virus with
nothing to fight it with
and abu sadat's relatives will have to
hunt again for more oxygen
for him soon alex crawford sky news
delhi